today on our show I'm going behind the
wheel of review baby driver so stick
around we'll be right back mark barnard
and Kev is off doing cab stuff as
Kevin's want to do so it's just me and I
figured if you're gonna talk about a
movie that takes place predominately
behind the wheel and what better place
to do it than behind the wheel so yeah
I'm gonna talk about baby driver which I
saw its open already so they are gonna
be some mild spoilers here but not
crazytown spoilers and also it's not a
kind of movie that it's about the
surprise that's not about ultimately
plot contrivance Azur character reveals
or any of that stuff it is about the
experience of this movie and the
experience this movie is kind of amazing
because the thing that it does better
than any movie I've ever seen before is
the idea of fusing music and action
together like it is it's a kinetic
experience the likes of which I haven't
really seen before and the use of music
within the scene is it's a fancy film
term called diegetic but it's the
characters within the scene are
listening to the music that the audience
is also listening to at the same time
and so the fusing of those two things
together makes for an incredibly
immersive experience and the car chases
in this movie there are there are three
or four really big ones and they are
among the best I've ever seen and and
there is something so incredibly
pleasurable about that it's hard to
discount and I like um one of my
foundational influences are the twin
pillars of Knight Rider and Dukes of
Hazzard those two shows were on the air
when I was a kid and I am all about the
pleasures of the car chase I'm all about
movies like Ronin and movies like road
warrior and movies like the first couple
of Jason Bourne films where what they're
doing is they're putting you behind the
wheel and they're making that experience
visceral for you and baby driver does
that in an incredibly way and incredibly
incredibly good way I will say that that
when I went into this movie I was
excited excited about this movie as any
movie that I can think about this year
and when I sat down at the beginning of
it and strapped in like I was giddy like
just tickles up my spine because the
first opening scene is amazing it's
scored to this John Spencer Blues
Explosion track called bell-bottoms
that's just all kinds of bottom thumping
deep funk and it's guitars and weirdo
Elvis in the middle and it's it's kind
of great and just watching Ansel Elgort
who despite that name seems to have made
himself a movie star or maybe that's the
only way you get to survive that names
my being a movie star but just watching
him behind the wheel and watching him do
as the movie posits the one thing he
does better than anybody else which is
Drive
is incredible it's it's an unbelievable
sequence and the movie is is basically
about this kid named baby behavior why
baby who at some point in his youth his
parents both died in a car accident
there's a little bit of Peter quill to
his origin story and that his parents
both died his mom was a singer but she
leaves for him or he has the one memory
he has of her is the iPod she gave him
for his birthday and a tape that he's
made of her singing the Commodore is
easy like Sunday morning
so his sort of origin story is tragedy
his and of course the tragedy that
happened in a car behind the wheel and
that's what he feels and that's what
what propels him forward and at one
point he he boosted a car that belonged
to Kevin Spacey's doc
everybody gets code names doc and and so
who doc caught him and decided that well
this kid was ballsy enough to steal my
car then then you know what I'm gonna do
I'm going to hire this person not even
super just hire more like indentured
servitude baby belongs to doc until he
works off the cost of the heist and has
the movie opens he's got he's finishing
a job he's got one more to go before
he's clear and then he gets to be his
own man again and you know the first
high studies on
there's there's a jon hamm and his
girlfriend Elsa Rodriguez I believe her
name is are playing you know bank
robbers and they're going in to rob a
bank and John Baron thought it was all
tanning up at awesome casting this
movie's bananas but to just watch those
those characters have fun to watch those
characters kind of cut loose and just be
bad unrepentantly bad and kind of you
know attractively bad the way that
Americans love their movie villains
which is there's a seduction to it you
want to be bad with those people and
that's that's the magnetism of a movie
like this and so they go on highest
highs goes off well baby's got one more
job maybe meets a girl you know it's
girl named Deborah who works at a diner
played by Lily James who is attractive
and sick and sort of dewy and awesome in
the way that again like femme fatales
not even femme fatales just fans and
movies like this are she represents the
innocence that was lost when he was a
boy and then and you absolutely
understand why he's attracted to her
because she's a movie star and she's
beautiful and she's attentive to him and
despite the fact that baby almost never
talks she manages to get some sense of
personality out of him and all that
stuff and it's really fun and it's
really sweet
and so of course baby's got one last job
to do this job goes a little bit awry
because of the presence of a fellow
named bats played by Jamie Foxx who is
hell on wheels does not pay for anything
that he could kill the person wanted to
get does not believe ultimately in any
sense of morality you know that the
whole system is built by Doc is one of a
code like there's a way to do this and
there's a way not to do this and the way
to do this is professionally and not
emotionally but do not expose yourself
to risks that do not pay off at the end
bats does not care about any less risks
and will kill and maim and blast his way
through everything to just get what he
wants
naturally this will end poorly for him
and ultimately also poorly for for baby
so you know and that's sort of the movie
it's a series of heists linked together
by the story of a guy who is learning to
connect to the world the world that he
had kept hidden behind a pair of
eardrums and a condition called tinnitus
which if you've ever been to a rock
concert if you've ever been out way too
late at a club if you're in a bar that's
just packed to the gills with people and
try to shout over them
it's that ringing in your ears that you
get when everything has been too loud
for too long
for baby that condition is heightened
and worsened and amplified to the point
where as it says in the trailer he's got
a hum in the drum and he uses the music
to drown it out the music is also what
partially helps them be the best getaway
driver in the world so that's the story
of this movie gonna show you this movie
you know it's it's I'm not going to say
it's deep it doesn't have to be deep
this is not a movie that is aiming for
depth and that's fine the the problem of
this movie for me despite all of the
pleasures that I talked about despite
all of the the tickles that you get in a
film like this is
is that there's a there's a sense of you
want the Cornetto trilogy as we remember
an Edgar Wright writer-director the
things that he does is and the things he
does so well it's both marry this visual
invention that that honestly nobody else
for my money puts on the screen with at
least in the Cornetto trilogy his other
three films show the Dead Hot Fuzz sorry
well the Cornetto trilogy Charlotte fuzz
and World's End plus Scott Pilgrim vs.
the world they are all about Arrested
Development they're all about men who
are unable or unwilling to move beyond
their adolescence which is a powerful
thing and you know Simon Pegg is a
fantastic avatar for that sort of thing
and Michael Cera just parentally looks
like he's never at puberty you know and
that that as a theme helps those visual
elements helps that invention to stick
together in a way that makes that makes
it incredibly enriching as experience to
watch this movie also has that in a way
but because baby is such a taciturn
character were never really invited
inside his world you know we don't know
really what life is like inside his head
we don't know the things that he's
fighting against internally that that
also inform his external world and as a
result this movie always kind of has you
at arm's length in regard to the main
character I mean is his wants are very
simple it's like I want to get in a car
with this girl and drive until we get
away from all of our problems which I
get but what I what the movie didn't
give me was the sense of what it's like
to be this guy and what is his internal
conflict that mirrors with his external
conflict for me if you're if you're
gonna posit a film that has a character
who is the best in the world at a thing
that has brought him nothing but but
heartache and separation from everybody
in his life that's tragic that's and and
that he's the best at it and that he
actually enjoys doing it like that's
kind of great if you play into that if
you make that part of the story if you
make the story here's a person who's the
best in the world at getaway driving
he's the fact that he has to do it but
also loves doing it and what that
presents to him as both the cause of his
confinement socially and emotionally as
well as the release for that as well as
his his get out of jail free card is the
car keys and the accelerator that's kind
of great you know the movie kind of
presents itself a little bit as a
musical and that the car chases are the
big music numbers which is a really
interesting way to go and
and has the potential for a lot of just
flair you know like you look at
something like Scott building which is
nothing but a visual feast for the eyes
this movie doesn't quite have that an
axe hey I was hoping for a little bit
more inside baby to be put on the screen
so that we know what it feels like for
this guy when he's behind the wheel not
just what it looks like what is that
what is the charge he gets when he
drives and like I said when he drives
it's great when the movie is not with
him behind the wheel or not in the
middle of an action sequence it has this
this this slight twinge of like remember
after Reservoir Dogs and Pulp Fiction
came out and every other movie
especially every other independent movie
was like a Tarantino knockoff where
everybody was like wearing black suits
and sunglasses and everybody was just
pop-culture pitter patter and all that
stuff I'm not saying that this is as bad
as some of those early Tarantino
knock-offs or even the latter day
Tarantino knockoffs but it's Reif
familiar there's there's absolutely a
sense that you've seen this sort of
thing before you've seen you know
criminals with code names who crack wise
and have you know fancy dialogue and and
feel
and in a way that lends to if not
caricature but cartoon and I say cartoon
in the best way and ain't not at all
pejorative way like there is nothing
wrong with a great cartoon and and I
feel like
there was there was a way in which Edgar
could have pushed this so that it felt
like an amazing cartoon which i think is
kind of what you want from a movie like
this you want that you know
physics-defying emotionally heightened
Hobie just adrenaline ride that's
something like a great cartoon could
give you this film doesn't quite get
there well when it gets there it's
sporadic and you just want to live in
that world more than visit that world
you know like when I came out of it I
felt like this movie tickled a lot more
than satisfying and there's nothing
wrong with a good tickle I'm not saying
that tickling is a bad thing I'm just
saying that what I wanted was just a
little bit more stake to go with the
incredibly awesome sizzle
all of this is not to say that I didn't
like this movie all of this is to say
but I just wanted more from this movie
that there's there's a road this movie
start to go down that I wish would
continue down that path and gave me just
a little bit more of this but for all of
them like listen you're gonna go you're
gonna spend here and these I spent
sixteen dollars to see this movie and
you will not regret having spent sixteen
dollars to see this movie but and then
and the reviews have all been rapturous
and overwhelmingly great and there's
there is always a sense of compare and
contrast when you look at stuff like
that like in you know in a in a
landscape where it's opening the week
after transformers and it's been a month
since Wonder Woman
and hoping and wanting something that
feels like a real movie and it does not
feel like a franchise starter or reboot
or remake or a brand extension or you
know a marketing win but feels like
actual cinema this delivers on that this
is not a movie that you've seen before
put together in this way you know like
it's it's in the same way that Tarantino
pulls some was influences like Tarantino
is a mixtape filmmaker in that and in
the best way he takes some of things he
loves he synthesizes it together into a
thing you haven't seen before but you're
always able to recognize the influences
same thing with Edgar right like you
know there's you can absolutely see the
things that he's drawing from you can
see the you know the driver and Ronin
and you can see you know in the samurai
and
and all of the great sort of heist
movies and con movies and driver movies
and road movies all put in a blender
made it to an awesome soundtrack by the
way I didn't talk about them and it's a
it's the kind of soundtrack and the
brilliance of the soundtrack is that
it's it's a needle drop soundtrack a
needle drop being and the term that you
use when we're dropping the needle on
this record and he was someone's gonna
play we're gonna pick up the needle and
then we're moving on and that's kind of
what the score is what he does is not
only does the two songs that you've
never heard of before
or you know unless you're like super
deep cut I got a wall of vinyl in my
house and I know all of these tracks but
he also chooses songs that were samples
like the origin for samples and other
songs that are bigger and more famous
that you already know in love like David
McCallum's the edge is the chief sample
for dr. Dre's the next episode you know
there's a track in there that's also the
sample one of the key samples for a De
La Soul song called Saint novo there's
the Harlem shuffle that you know the
Rolling Stones covered tequila is in it
but not that aquila by the champs but a
tequila by it by another band who was
covering the champs and so as these
songs that are familiar but in versions
you haven't heard before and they all
work in and amongst and with the
emotional texture of the movie and it's
a great experience it's a great it's a
textual experience the thing that I just
wish for this movie was that it was a
little bit more of an emotional
experience and an emotional experience
it was driven by your main character now
I driven I made funds so listen you're
gonna go see this movie you're going to
enjoy this movie you were going to
you're gonna feel a charge on this movie
you're gonna feel a release out of this
movie you're gonna sit back and wonder
why people don't make more movies like
this
because again it is cars and highway and
assembly we talked about Panama Ford's
like it's at its core it's a detective
thing this is a this is a genre this is
a discipline that has been part of
Hollywood for as long as I've been cars
you know they let us put a person behind
the wheel who does something we've never
seen a person do before and let's let's
build the kinetise ISM of an everyday
object that everybody has the command of
a car and turn it into a thing and have
a person do something behind the wheel
of that object that you've never seen
done before
and this movie delivers on that
absolutely you know and you know you
know me like if you've been watching fat
man not Batman long enough you know me
that that I can still have the twin the
twin poles of here's a thing that I
found enjoyment dim here's the thing
that I thought achieved what it set out
to achieve and delivered and an
entertainment experience that I think
you'll be satisfied with but I still
felt that there was a little bit wanting
from it and and that is the awesome
thing about being able to keep two ideas
in your head at the same time is that
you know it can also be both things it
can be an incredible cinematic
experience it can be a well a
well-earned night out but it can also be
a learning thing it can also be a let's
let's look at it and see what it might
have done to just get over a little bit
more of a hump but if you don't have
this weekend to see a movie if you're
going out this weekend for a good time
you could absolutely do far far worse
than maybe driver in fact I hear there's
a Transformers movie in the theaters
that I cannot work up the enthusiasm to
see because life is too short for the
fifth iteration of a movie that was only
really ever good once
instead go see a movie that you haven't
seen before that will tickle and hey who
doesn't love a good slap and tickle
right so that's it for this week's show
Kevin we'll be back shortly and we will
get into it we will also deliver later a
review of war for the plan of the Apes
which I also saw but which comes out a
little bit later so we'll get to that
little bit later but yeah for fat man of
Batman I've been mark barnard behind the
wheel probably breaking like a dozen
traffic laws but don't tell anybody so
come back soon same fat time same
cat-channel SModcast calm or youtube.com
slash Kevin Smith
[Music]
[Applause]
you